what a day what a day I thought we were
done for the week and finished up the
Friday show we were all good and went
running 70 degrees here in Boston in
February amazing but no huge huge
breaking stories the Trump White House
banning a bunch of media outlets from a
White House press briefing today I'm
going to talk about that Russian flags
appearing at CPAC today during Donald
Trump's speech so much so much to
discuss and this is all just like the
couple of hours since we wrapped up
shows for the week so a lot to discuss
I'm just going to wait a second let
people drop in here
super chat is on you can use super chat
if you want what else yeah just just so
much going on I'm just waiting a second
to let people connect here it is
absolutely unbelievable what is going on
with this administration and I've got
articles to look at I'm gonna dig into
them in a second white house blocks news
organizations from press briefing we
also have the CPAC Trump Flags but
they're Russian flags article on
DailyKos brilliant troll hands out tiny
Trump Russian flags right before Trump's
CPAC speech so much to discuss much much
much to discuss seems like every day
just about every day there is something
I will be doing live shoutouts and
thank-yous to any new members that sign
up during the stream david pakman.com
slash membership we have a coupon code
it's I voted 17 let's just dig in okay
so there are a number of reports that
today there was an off-camera White
House press briefing okay so you can
have your normal press briefing where
reporters go in Sean Spicer comes out
and it's film right everything is filmed
and then you also can have an off-camera
press briefing where reporters are
allowed in they can ask questions they
can write down answers but this is not a
an on-camera
briefing okay that's the context CNN and
other news outlets were blocked earlier
today from attending one of these
off-camera press briefings and reporters
appear to have been hand-picked to
attend low and behold it was the
generally friendlier reporters or
reporters from friendlier or so-called
friendlier news outlets who were allowed
to attend the New York Times the Los
Angeles Times Politico BuzzFeed excluded
from this meeting as well as CNN this
was a press briefing that was in Sean
Spicer's office instead of in the press
briefing room where do we start
okay where do we start I actually don't
know where to start number one if the
idea is that you get more access if
you're friendly to Trump and you get
berated if you're not friendly to Trump
that's a major issue when it comes to
freedom of the press because you could
be a trumpet and you could say hey press
is free to write whatever they want but
that doesn't mean they have an
unrevealed let's we'll we'll have and
we'll be given more access to the
president the problem with this of
course is that I've said before that if
you look at some of the authoritarian
tendencies that are going on right now
they are very similar to what we saw in
Europe between World War one and World
War two before you start saying David
are you saying Trump is Hitler no I'm
not saying Trump is Hitler what I'm
saying is and there are a number of
academics including one that I'm hoping
to interview soon experts on early
twentieth century Europe who are making
it very clear that there are
similarities between what is happening
with Donald Trump and the attacks on
media are part of it the idea that you
can only trust Trump fake news plays
into this and now actually not allowing
media outlets that I don't even know
that it's fair to say that they're anti
Trump in fact I think it's pretty clear
that that's not fair to say I think
really what we're talking about is
they are applying some rational thought
and critical thinking when they report
on what Donald Trump says and does so
very very dangerous in that sense
there's also never far behind when it
comes to what's going on with the Trump
administration and trumpets is that
things are happening that if we believe
that trumpets have a consistent
Republican ideology they should be
really opposed to okay and if you think
about well although I I believe that
actually the Republicans are not the
party of free speech Republicans talk
about being the party of free speech
Republicans talk about being the party
of the free market Republicans talk
about being the the the anti-fascists
call them what you will
and they should all be saying wait a
second it's really important that we
actually have a critical press and that
you don't see government stifling or
attempting to influence press in this
way and this is a very very clear
attempt to say hey if you want access
you'd better as Donald Trump has said in
the past right good and of course most
of these news outlets saying it's
absolutely insane by the way Breitbart
news a conservative news outlet The
Washington Times a conservative news
outlet and one American news network and
I call these conservative news outlets
really these are propaganda news outlets
I don't know whether you know I've
talked on the show about how the term
fake news is increasingly used as a
catch-all for news you don't agree with
we don't we don't have to use it
propaganda news I think is is mostly
fine although we could certainly make
the case that bacon you should be used
Breitbart Washington Times and if you
haven't heard of one American news
network by the way look into that it is
incredibly disturbing they were allowed
in and the the exclusion of these news
organizations is absolutely insane of
course the New York Times is fighting
back New York Times executive editor Dan
biquette
quote nothing like this has ever
happened at the White House in our long
history of covering multiple
administration's of different parties we
strongly protest the inclusion the
exclusion of the New York Times and the
other news organizations free media
access to a transparent government is
obviously crucial to national interest
there are trumpets who love this okay
and Donald Trump has the the psychology
term for this would be priming Donald
Trump has primed through everything that
he has done throughout the campaign and
since Trump has primed committed crumb
pused slow information trumpets the
those would be malleable minds where
they'll just go with whatever Trump says
without seeing whether it even matches
their supposed principles
Trump has primed a lot of his supporters
to fundamentally just not believe
anything that is negative about Trump
right and I've said it before I'll say
it again healthy skepticism about what
media is reporting to say it's important
is an understatement
okay healthy skepticism of what media is
reporting is a key aspect it should be
part of a media literacy education that
everybody gets should be taught early on
middle school high school at the latest
okay but straight out believing that
what your fearless leader tells you and
I use that term sarcastically Donald
Trump is true and anything else you you
simply cannot believe that's problematic
and supporting the handpicking inclusion
or exclusion of of media outlets on the
basis of how friendly they appear to be
is incredibly disturbing incredibly
disturbing super chat is on feel free to
send the super chat if you want
yesterday yesterday's live stream had I
don't remember how many but a record
number of super chats also any new
subscribers during the live stream at
david pakman.com slash membership i will
give a live shout out and thank you to i
already have - I have Dale Morris and
Corey Collins Dale Morris and Corey
Collins both signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership
using the coupon code I voted 17 that
gives you 40% off membership is the way
our program is funded now over three
hundred and twenty five thousand YouTube
subscribers if you're not subscribed
please do and the six and a half roughly
hours a week of content that we produce
it's funded through our audience
primarily through membership okay so I
voted seventeen forty percent off
have at it thank yous and and and
shoutouts will continue okay a bunch of
people in the chat and an email and all
over the place saying David did you see
the Russian flags at Trump's CPAC speech
so I still have not heard definitively
how much of this was sort of a
deliberate troll I don't really know
that the background and I apologize I'm
just going to pause just for a second
and block a couple of people for the
chat I'm really pretty liberal on the
chat on our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash read it we rarely
remove any comments or ban anybody but
sometimes people are just such vile
trolls that we've got stuff to talk
about here right i mean we don't we're
not going to clog up the chat chat with
the nonsense so i just blocked a couple
people and we could block more right why
not there's no limit the the block
button is free folks all right okay so
we found out that during Trump's speech
right before Donald Trump's speech
speech at CPAC today people were seen
holding trump flags right and the flag
has it says Trump on it but people seem
to not notice that these are Russian
flags and at a certain point somebody
apparently realized it and there's
pictures of people going through the
crowd with CPAC badges taking away the
flags and I actually don't know I I only
heard some of the speech I didn't watch
any of it so I don't know if the flags
were visible on camera while while the
speech was going
but it was absolutely absolutely
brilliant and I sometimes I call this
type of trolling brilliantly subtle
trolling this isn't really subtle it's
it's counting on the the ignorance of
the crowd there who wouldn't know a
Russian flag if it smacked them in the
face which it almost did at CPAC today
so really funny of people calling this
fake news of course nothing fake about
it absolutely true there's pictures
that's it all right we've got a super
chat from Isaiah row in the amount of $5
Isaiah says secular talk the amazing
atheist and sargon of akkad are arguing
over whether or not Trump's actions
violate the First Amendment what are
your thoughts I'm curious what you mean
that they're arguing about it are they
arguing about it on on Twitter or where
I don't know where they are arguing
about it okay so this is we have a
really great interview on our YouTube
channel called I'm checking now I think
it's called the do you understand the
First Amendment or do people actually
understand the First Amendment so the
question is a fair one which is is Trump
banning the truck is the Trump
administration banning certain media
outlets who happen to be media outlets
that you could argue have been doing a
more fact fact-based critique and
analysis of the things that Donald Trump
has done are is that a violation of the
First Amendment First Amendment says
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof or abridging
the freedom of speech or of the press I
am NOT a lawyer I don't think anybody
thought I was a lawyer but in my reading
of this this is not abridging the
freedom of the press
in terms of limiting what the press can
say it's not a threat to shut down
certain media outlets if they write the
wrong thing but there's no doubt that
it's a signal that your access to the
administration will be limited so my non
legal opinion having interviewed a
number of experts on the First Amendment
that this is not a violation of the
First Amendment but there is no doubt
that it's a completely Thorat Aryan
action okay we'll see I will absolutely
I'm gonna be seeing actually a couple
lawyer friends over the weekend and I'll
see what what their thoughts on that are
anybody else that needs to get blocked
as I mentioned before the the block
chant the block button is free and I'm
willing to use it I see a lot of
productive discussion but also let's see
I think Gisele Phillips has earned
herself a block talking about locking up
Podesta the molester that I've seen if
I'm noticing what you're saying when the
comments are flying by it at a mile a
minute there's a problem anybody else
who needs to get blocked we'll give it a
few more minutes I'm not paying
attention to that all the time but keep
me posted on that okay it is it's free
and I won't hesitate to use it okay
david pakman.com slash membership is
where you sign up for membership that's
the number one funding source for the
show I want to give a big thank you to
Beverly Martinez who just signed up she
did not use the coupon code
I voted 17 ivote at 17 gives you a 40%
discount you get a hundred percent of
the member benefits but you pay 40
percent less that's pretty good okay
that's pretty good so you can use that
coupon code you get instant access to
the bonus show it's a Members Only extra
show this is not published to our public
YouTube feed every day we do an extra
show called the bonus show for our paid
subscribers it's all happening there
okay a $2 $2 super chat from Starchild
158 doesn't have a question just says
smoke weed everyday' okay so that's a
message to you from apparently worth $2
to that user smoke weed everyday' that
is the message that they're sending over
to you and also thank you to kendra
jours kendra jours who has just signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
ok so we've talked about Trump the Trump
administration
keeping out certain media outlets
understandably seen as less friendly to
the Trump administration from a a non an
off-camera White House press briefing
today I've talked a little bit about
these brilliant just brilliantly
executed troll flags handed out at
Trump's CPAC speech today Russian flags
that say Trump on them of course your
average trumpet would not recognize a
Russian flag and clearly they didn't
countless pictures on social media that
I'm looking at right now that are
absolutely hilarious and you know people
like to say David you're unfairly
suggesting that trumpets are less
informed or more extreme or more than a
phobic or racist or whatever I'm not
coming up with that right i mean we have
poll after poll that that has
demonstrated that and i it's it's
stunning to me that anyone's even
actually trying to make that argument
anymore i I would think that they would
sort of defend it as being okay or
justified or whatever but it's
fascinating to me that people are still
arguing oh no no there's nothing to that
okay couple other things I want to
discuss on Monday's show I am going to
be talking about more elements of the
Trump blackmail Russian dossier that
have indeed now been confirmed and we
first heard from Trump that the
existence of the dossier is fake blatant
lie I mean just lie lie lie lie just
factually untrue the existence of the
dossier is real once it became
impossible for Donald to deny the
existence of the dossier he shifted to
its contents are all completely untrue
and indeed initially we did not have
confirmation about the contents some of
them were very believable some of them
more salacious like that Donald Trump is
sexually aroused by urinating on Russian
prostitutes but it was all unconfirmed
initially but drip drip drip it all
started to trickle in and we have now
learned that a number of the
Communications the conversations that
are alleged to have taken place in that
Russian dossier have indeed been
confirmed we have also now learned that
some of the allegations from the dossier
about Carter page have been confirmed an
oil executive and foreign policy adviser
we have also learned that some of the
allegations from that blackmail dossier
regarding Paul Manafort Donald Trump's
disgraced former campaign manager have
also been confirmed so we're gonna be
talking about that on Monday okay Isaiah
Rowe sending a five-dollar super chat
saying any thoughts on the DNC debate
isn't keith ellison the best choice for
the future of the party i'm not sure
about that i am not sure about that I've
not taken a position on this because I
am unsure about whether keith ellison is
the best way forward for the the future
of the party
tune in on Monday okay we'll be talking
about that on Monday
mattias Bergeron sending a twenty
Norwegian kroner super chat saying will
I do another appearance on the DP
podcast I assume matthias is referring
to drunken peasants and I absolutely
would be glad to if they want to have me
write I it's not
I have no fundamental right to appear
with the drunken peasants whenever I
want not a violation of free speech or
anything like that I would be glad to
appear I had a good time talking to them
would be glad to be back on five-dollar
super chat from user triple7 nightshade
saying can you ask your lawyer friends
if this has ever happened I don't
understand this question I guess okay so
I mentioned I was going to ask my lawyer
friends whether they thought that Trump
keeping a few media outlets out of the
press briefing is a violation of the
First Amendment so I guess the question
is has this ever happened you don't
really need to talk to a lawyer about
that you could just look up and take a
historical perspective on that and from
what the New York Times reported today
they say that as long as they've been
covering white houses this has not
happened that that's what the New York
Times is saying and I think on this
issue there
probably pretty trustworthy thank you to
Karin Makani Karin Makani has just
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code I vote
at 17 that dropped her membership to
only 3 bucks a month pay dearly $36 also
thank you to gregory lassen gregory who
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership just now and using the coupon
code I voted 17 keep the memberships
coming and I'll keep these shoutouts and
thank-yous going ok people are saying
that Brielle Jones should be blocked and
you know what Brielle Jones has been
Brielle Jones has been leaving all sorts
of it actually came to my attention when
there's like a major troll on our
channel the different people that helped
manage the the YouTube comments let me
know about it and Brielle Jones his name
actually came up in our morning meeting
saying it might be time to to to hit
Brielle with the ban or block button and
indeed I have done that all sorts of you
know I'm not even gonna mention the the
stuff she's been saying but it's pretty
vile okay a five dollar super chat from
ruel James five Canadian dollar super
chat rule says love your show was
wondering if you ever take on interns
and how one would inquire about becoming
an intern on your show not only do we
take on interns sometimes interns get
hired in fact we we now have segment
producer Noah Ferguson who was an intern
for us for a couple of semesters and now
he has been hired and as a segment
producer and is doing a lot of
background research on stories that that
that we do and so yes internships are
based in our Boston studio we currently
have a great intern named melody who has
been doing a lot of great stuff social
media work writing really really great
stuff to apply you go to our website
david pakman.com click the contact page
and send in just sort of a general
inquiry and then we'll respond with
instructions and then you can send in
your resume and all sorts of stuff ok
but yes we do have interns and sometimes
into
get hired which is a really really great
thing okay
also on Monday marijuana we had a two
dollar super chat sent earlier which
said only smoke weed everyday' it was
succinct it was to the point but we do
have cannabis related news the White
House has announced that they're
expecting the US Justice Department to
step up the crackdown on recreational
marijuana and their there are major
legal questions here right and to sort
of remind you we've seen marijuana
legalization and decriminalization
happen pretty significantly during the
Obama White House and the Obama Justice
Department took the approach of saying
marijuana is still illegal federally but
we're not going to we're not going to go
after or target individuals in states
that have legalized or decriminalized as
long as they're following the laws of
those states that's not the default
position that the the Justice Department
has to take right the Justice Department
could take a different position and they
could ignore state law what's amazing to
me and I've been talking about this for
months at this point okay you have
states rights as a concept that the
American right the conservatives claim
to love but they only love it as long as
it meets what they want which is hey no
federal restrictions on guns states
rights states get to decide no federal
legalization of abortion each state
should get to decide and ban it if they
want no federal legalization of same-sex
marriage if States want to ban same-sex
marriage they should be allowed to ban
same-sex marriage but all of a sudden
when it comes to hey states want to
legalize marijuana then they should be
allowed to do it states rights right
right
wrong all of a sudden no it's going to
be a federal decision that states are
not allowed to do that so so that that
states rights hypocrisy is absolutely
incredible
okay so it looks like Brielle Jones has
immediately created another account and
is back and I guess I'll just block her
again I don't know it must must be a
different account what's your opinion if
someone just says Pakman is a Jew boy is
that band worthy I mean it's true I'm
Jewish and I'm male
it doesn't seem particularly egregious
but it's not exactly productive right so
I don't know I don't know how the
audience is feeling about that in terms
of in terms of had warrants warrants a
ban thanks to James Scott James Scott
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code
I voted 17 that is that's huge
I mean it's it's tremendous we have the
best members people are telling me
they're telling me they're there
absolutely tremendous also big THANK YOU
to Eve Clemens who has we've been
chatting here went to david pakman.com
slash gear and bought some of our coffee
we have two types of coffee we have an
espresso blend called progressive
wake-up call and we have a drip blend
called freedom of the press and they're
both available at david pakman.com slash
gear we have a 15 what is our I don't
know what currency this is is this is
this uh well I have no idea what it is
fifteen are I'm curious what currency
that is from Fabricio
aldohn a who is asking if I'll ever
speak a little bit of Spanish on the
show yes I've done it before
I did it on the last live stream but you
need you need to leave people wanting
more I can't just willy-nilly start
speaking Spanish all the time or it
won't have any cachet you know I am
genuinely curious what oh those are
Brazilian rails is that what people are
saying I have no idea how much that is
in US dollars yeah okay so I guess
that's I guess that's what it is before
I move on another thank you to Diana
Rosario Diana Rosario has just signed up
for membership at david pakman.com
slash membership we have this thing
called the bonus show that is available
to you someone joking that 15 Brazilian
rails is is a penny let's figure out how
much it is fifteen two US dollars
oh it's basically five bucks it's 482
okay so very nice a roughly $5 Super
chat there so we have this thing called
the bonus show and the bonus show is
sometimes an extension of the regular
show where we just have more stories
news stories whatever sometimes though
we get into things that are going on
behind the scenes sometimes we'll talk
about internal poll results etc etc we
had a really great story about polling
regarding whether Americans are fearing
another war and we now have a majority
of Americans who believe that during
Donald Trump's first term which may be
his only term we don't know at this
point that more than 50% of Americans
believe that it is likely that we will
have another war during Donald Trump's
first first term and and producer Pat
and I had this conversation on the bonus
show where some things we have sort of
longer unstructured conversations about
what country would it be with and we
sort of came up that we thought Syria
Iran or a reengagement in Iraq would be
the most likely engagement so that's a
discussion on today's bonus show and of
course that's one of the great one of
the many member benefits that you get
when you sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership and a if you want a
discount I voted 17 is the coupon code
kelly Limburg has sent a twenty dollar
super chat no question no comment just
participating in the super chat for 20
bucks thank you so much to to kelly
Limburg alright upcoming interviews that
we have yesterday I sort of did a little
preview on the live stream as far as
interviews coming up this week and just
to go over that real quick Mike
Papantonio on Monday will talk to us
about his major I mean hundreds of
millions of dollars settlement for
something like thirty five hundred
plaintiffs against DuPont DuPont if
you're familiar with those Teflon
nonstick pans
there's a byproduct that is used or not
a pipe there's a there's a product that
is used in the production of those
non-stick pans that is a Chris Inogen
and Mike Papantonio and the law firm
down in Pensacola Levin Papantonio
representing roughly 3,500 at last count
plaintiffs and they have settled for
something like I think it was let me
pull up my notes here something like 671
million dollars in cash huge I mean many
people being diagnosed with cancer
linked specifically to that that product
that that chemical then Tuesday and
Wednesday we are going to be
interviewing Stefan G&A who is an expert
on the history of obesity dieting diet
myths nutrition etc etc he is awesome
and it's going to be it's it's such a
great interview that we're going to have
to do it in two parts and then on
Thursday we'll be speaking to military
veteran Ronald Frey I won't even tell
you what that's about but it's huge and
you should you should definitely look
look up Ronald Frey the following week
is arguably just as good people are
telling me it's going to be just as good
on Monday and Tuesday we'll be speaking
with Professor Marcelo gleiser who is
Brazilian and I believe he currently
teaches here in Boston or technically
Cambridge at MIT and we're going to be
talking to him we're gonna do a two-part
interview with him part one will be
about the concept of reality and how the
the our understanding of what reality is
has changed in terms of a scientific
perspective perspective over time and
then we're going to get into what
science can tell us about right versus
wrong okay
okay I'm gonna get to borrow two swords
in a second but there are a bunch of
people that need to get blocked here I'm
not even gonna mention their names but
we've got one too yes we are gonna ban
Sean s who is just I mean it's just a
vile though who I actually okay let me
let me deal with Berra two swords here
first and then I want to talk to you
about trolls a little bit
Barra or bara bara two swords has sent
the $5 super chat saying who are the
young leaders of the Democratic Party
who have the will to fight the
Republican Party to break their hold on
their legislature it depends how young
you mean a lot of people like Tulsi
Gabbard the Castro brothers are
increasingly growing growing a following
you know I think young when we're
talking about the average age of
Senators which I believe is let's see
average age of the US senator
61 years old when you're talking about a
body a legislative body where the
average age is 61 years old youth could
be someone who's 48 right so it really
depends on what you mean but I think
that the next year should be a sort of
soul-searching moment within the the
local state representative state
senators etc to see who there is that
that could be brought into the sort of
national national milieu so to speak
political milieu okay some people
talking about me having a rat tail I
hate to break it to you but this this is
my Semitic hairline there's no rat tail
it's it's just that's just my hair okay
that may that may be shocking to some
people okay let me just do a couple more
bands just for good measure people
really getting upset by some of the
people that are there okay let me talk a
little bit about trolling I find it a
distraction when the channel gets filled
with trolls or whatever but I also
really find it sad because like I'm a
news consumer you know I turn on CNN or
Fox News or MSNBC most of the anchors I
can identify just at first glance I'm
aware of who's talking about what
stories I watched some satirical shows i
watch regular news shows independent
shows whatever I think I've probably
actually contacted any of these shows
hand
of times and I contact them because I
want to express a view about a
particular issue and it's really pretty
rare right I don't know what would have
to be going on in my mind where I think
to start contacting media hosts with
racist xenophobic anti-semitic slurs
insults or any of that right so and and
so when I think about it wait a second
I don't even know anybody personally who
would be doing that type of thing
you must be in a pretty bad place you
must be in a pretty sad place to be
doing that and so on the one hand it's
annoying and we want to get rid of the
riffraff because we're doing a show here
we're up to I don't even know how many
millions of views per month every ever
every platform is blowing up we've got
you know a record 400 new paid
subscribers this one than 325 thousand
on YouTube we're move we're trying to
get beyond that the the riff raff but
it's there and in some sense I do find
it sad because these people something
must be going on in their lives where
they think that it makes sense to be you
know insulting people you don't even
personally know right so okay that
that's my brief thought about trolls and
that type of thing we've got a $2.00
super chat from Dunstable ramsey to
canadian dollar's saying sativa or in
indecent I never know if it's indicia
okay I know enough about pot to know
that that refers to the two broader
types of marijuana I think one of them
from what my friends have told me one of
them is sort of like a downer and one is
an upper or whatever I couldn't tell you
I've been pretty clear that I have no
problem whatsoever with with marijuana I
think it should be legalized I think it
should be decriminalized etc etc but I I
sort of the mindset that smoking
anything is bad for you it's bad for
your lungs even if you take a banana
leaf right hey it's produce it's a fruit
if you start smoking it it's bad for
your lungs so I don't really know I
can't comment too much more about that
we've got a ten dollar super chat from
Felipe Garcia who says Spicer was asked
about ant
Muslim hate groups tripling during
Trump's campaign his response was
radical Islamic terrorists what can we
do to help bring this hateful response
to life okay I haven't seen that now I
don't know you know I think that the
term radical Islamic terror is actually
a perfectly fine term to use as long as
it's only applied to the people as long
as it's applied correctly I think that
radical Islamic terror is a thing I
think radical white nationalist terror
in the United States is a thing all
sorts of radical terror are things I
don't know the context I didn't see that
clip okay so I can't really comment on
it but I am NOT of the mindset that we
should we can't say something like
radical jihad okay I think it's okay to
say that as long as we're not saying all
Muslims believe in radical jihad right
$5 super chat from Tara drew no comment
no question thank you very much we also
have a number of new members showing up
here Chris B Kok signing up with coupon
code I voted 17 on the website david
pakman.com slash membership now gets
instant access to all the great member
benefits diana cortez signing up with
coupon code I voted seventeen Brian
Henny I think would be the way it's
pronounced signing up just now
Peter Buckland just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership thank you I
mean this this is our number one funding
source and back like a year ago a good
month would be maybe about a hundred a
hundred new members in a month would be
really really good and we we have four
hundred new members so far in February
and it is only the 24th of the month so
I'm glad people are understanding the
importance of supporting independent
media Nicholas Benny has sent a $2 super
chat I recognize the name I think
Nicholas Ari I believe you'll remember
maybe not I think Nicholas is a member
have I ever done speed dating or online
dating I have never done speed dating
years and years ago I did have any
number of online dating profiles
and yeah I wish I had more to say about
it
but I don't and people also saying I
haven't done speed-dating have I ever
done speed I have not but a very very
good question
I have not I I have not done speed okay
a couple other things that I want to
talk about looking further down the line
we have a thread at david pakman.com
slash read it so we have this reddit
discussion forum right and this reddit
discussion forum it's free and we have
podcast listeners radio listeners
YouTube viewers it's a really great
community which is nearly 3000 of our
audience members are participating on
our reddit discussion forum you can find
it at david pakman.com slash read it we
have a number of different threads there
if you have stories to suggest for the
show that you want covered that's a
great that is a great place to suggest
them if you have guests that you want us
to interview that is also a great place
to suggest guests and it's also just a
great place to see sort of like the what
would we call it not the atmosphere just
sort of like the perspective of
different elements of our audience I
find that people who listen to an hour
podcast are very different in terms of
their connection to the show then people
who are watching a three-minute clip for
example on YouTube
and so it's interesting to see those
worlds come together and you have radio
listeners and TV viewers and all sorts
of different people happening there and
I encourage you to check it out I think
it's really really good so check that
out a few interesting things number one
the entire Milo you Napoles thing from
earlier this week has been a really big
topic on the reddit discussion forum now
the great thing is you can filter it out
so there's been like a dozen or so
threads different aspects of the Milo
you nopales scandal but if you want to
filter those out you easily can also of
significant interest a number of people
posting already about what's been going
on it's
pack okay so we've been talking about
CPAC on the livestreams not so much on
the show on Monday I think it's pretty
safe to say that I will be talking about
the Donald Trump speech at CPAC and
obviously what's been going on with the
the the banning of cert the exclusion of
certain media outlets okay Vanessa has
sent the $5 Super chat where she said
why do you think Republicans are staying
quiet while Trump and his administration
dismantle America okay to that this is a
very good question two-part answer to
Vanessa and in order to end this is such
a good question that I actually need to
pull up a couple notes here two things
number one Donald Trump is the perfect
straw man okay check out that video on
YouTube the Republicans have maybe been
quiet in terms of publicly criticizing
Donald Trump some have some have not but
Republicans have been passing a ton of
absolutely insane stuff House Joint
Resolution 38 which removed basic common
sense Obama era regulations regarding
coal mining House Joint Resolution 48
which removed an SEC rule that requires
oil companies were for report foreign
payments payments to foreign governments
in the Trump era of the Russia debacle
we all of a sudden want to remove a rule
that says if domestic oil companies send
payments to foreign governments we don't
need to know about that absolutely and
totally insane okay and there's a very
long list of these I won't read the
entire thing but you can check out the
YouTube clip Donald Trump is the perfect
straw man secondly though if Donald
Trump's approval rating continues to
decrease and if it gets into the 20s as
we approach the midterm elections you
were going to see no doubt about it you
are going to see Republicans jumping
ship because it's really all about
self-preservation for them and if being
quiet about Trump helps them get
reelected in 2018 then that's what
they're going to do if denouncing Trump
helps them get reelected
in 2018 then that's what they're going
to do all right we've got a bunch of
different super chats here mr. Tate has
sent a $5 super chat saying I heard
CRISPR has green light to be used on
fetuses thoughts I believe it's just
British scientists for now thanks for
being fair and educated yeah I have not
read that story yet for people who don't
know CRISPR is I hope I'm explaining
this in a in a sort of reasonable way
CRISPR is a way that you can sort of
edit genome and it's controversial for a
number of different reasons and of
course we know that a variety of
different constituencies have problems
with different type of fetal research
that is going on I haven't seen the
specifics mr. Tate so I'm not able to
comment okay Felipe Garcia $5 super chat
saying please look up Spicer's response
to the question anti-muslim hate groups
are being equated to hating Islamic
terrorists by Trump okay I'm going to
look it up
absolutely Fabricio I'll donate sending
a 15 Brazilian ray all super chat saying
just wanted to say that the joke made
about my donation being one penny made
by a user sounded racist to me well I
don't know if it's racist okay that
that's fair let's explore that I think
this is a good opportunity to explore
something so fabrizio is saying that I
said how much is 15 Brazilian rails in
US dollars and somebody said it's a
penny and the implication if we are to
believe it's racist I guess it would be
that if you're Brazilian you're not
white so therefore you're assuming any
country that has people that aren't
white has a currency it's not worth much
the reality is Brazil is actually
relatively diverse racially you have
white brown and black people in Brazil I
don't know that it's racist fabrizio I
don't know that it's racist I think it's
just complete ignorance about the idea
that any South American country couldn't
possibly have currency that's of any
value and I think it's more ignorant
than
thing else but I don't I don't think
that that's racist I think it's
important to only say only call out
racism when we can actually say that
there was racism homme terreno has sent
a ten US dollar super chat saying will
we get through this and prevail we will
get through this we will get through
this in the sense that this is not the
end of the United States as as we know
it prevail if you're saying are
progressives ultimately going to prevail
the country does continue to move to the
left so that that definitely gives me
gives me some hope but we also don't
really have a democracy Princeton study
you can look up which says we have an
oligarchy if you are a big corporation
or if you are a rich person it is much
more likely that what you want to see
our politicians do is going to be done
by our politicians so prevail is a
subjective term but I believe that we
will absolutely survive a five dollar
super chat from a W admin saying if
Trump Mint maintains his extremely low
approval rating throughout his
presidency do you think he will be
primary in 2020 I see it as more likely
that Trump will be convinced not to run
for re-election than that he will be
primary in the same way that I believe
if it gets to where Trump might be
impeached he will resign rather than
face impeachment impeachment
I have friends yesterday I was talking
to about this who were saying Trump's
ego would never have him resign because
it's basically an admission that he
failed I don't know about that I don't
know about that I think if Trump the
question would be if you could get Trump
to believe he was going to be impeached
then you might get him to resign in
advance in advance of that okay but I
don't yeah I just don't see a real
primary against Trump okay couple new
members we have Kara Campbell Kara thank
you so much for signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership i love how
as the allegations that I'm a Jew
[ __ ] flow by we actually have people
making a commitment to independent media
and signing up for memberships the way
Cara Campbell just did the way that Bob
of vashaun just did and the way like a
dozen people have done during the live
stream kind of funny quite quite a quite
a contrast but we do have a coupon code
I voted 17 gives you a discount off of
membership memberships the best long
list of member benefits that are
available including a show just for our
paid subscribers we have a five dollar
Canadian dollar super chat by the way
I'm looking for a weekend to get up to
Montreal and it's just freezing up there
I keep checking I tell my girlfriend
okay let's see if let's see if next
weekend it's not completely freezing in
Montreal and it's like a high of 9
degrees or something like that let's see
how okay they currently have a blizzard
warning am I ever going to be able to
get back to Montreal I guess in the
summer yeah next weekend it'll be a high
of 24 in Montreal I'm not exactly good
weather for walking around okay back to
Dunstable ramsey where in the world can
Trump visit without drawing huge public
protests will international
demonstrations hurt Trump in the USA or
help him
okay so sort of a two-part question I
think that okay where could Trump visit
without drawing huge protest
I think the Philippines I think the
Philippines because his buddy there
Rodrigo Duterte the president of the
Philippines would just say hey if you
protest Trump it's gonna be legal for
people to kill you on the street the way
he's done with drug dealers or suspected
drug dealers or even drug users so I
think that he could safely visit the
Philippines because Rodrigo Duterte
would say don't protest because we'll
kill you we will allow the legal killing
will international demonstrations hurt
Trump in the USA or help him I believe
that they will help them and here's why
there is such particularly anti-european
bias among the
right in the United States that if you
are already concerned by what Trump is
doing your opinion of Trump is is
already pretty pretty damn low and
you're not really going to be influenced
further by international concern or
hatred of Donald Trump if you are an
America first er if you are a xenophobic
nativist if you are a low information
grifter which actually applies more to
the grifter part applies more to Trump's
team then to the to his followers there
are low information trumpets you already
are going to see criticism from other
countries as what do they know they're
the people we want to keep out of here
so if anything you're going to not
impact those who are against Trump and
for the most part you're going to just
embolden those who already I think that
we should be ignoring what people from
from other countries are are telling us
big thank you big big thank you to Alex
bode Corliss who signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership normal prices six bucks a
month $60 a year coupon code
I voted 17 40 percent discount makes it
three dollars and 60 cents a month or
$36 for the year this is very cheap but
the more members we have the more shows
we can do and the more production value
improves etc etc okay so please do sign
up shoutouts and thank-yous will
continue five British Pound super chat
from stabby 666 I was in London over the
well just before New Year's during our
pre New Year's break had a great time I
say this with peace and love I did not
find British cuisine to be particularly
good went to a few pug pubs wet too
fish and chips the fish and chips was
great did some Street fish and chips and
it was all fantastic but the actual
British cuisine other than that I did
not find to be great I had the best
Indian food of my life actually in in
London and found some really great spots
went to a place called I think it's
called des Shoom which actually had I
think it's like Bombay style breakfast
and it was extraordinary and then also
went to a place outside of downtown
London called Indian zing and it was
really great okay but back to stabby
triple sixes five pound super chat what
would you do if your parents told you
they'd voted for Trump would you send
them for psychiatric examinations well
my dad is a psychiatrist so there would
be no shortage of people who'd be able
to to do the examination listen my
parents were super liberal it's I
couldn't even conceive of that and david
pakman show producer Pat Forde has
talked about how hit although he never
really discussed politics too much with
his family that there are definitely
some conservatives in his family and
that it basically becomes sort of it's
just a political discussions are a
non-starter and it's just just basically
not uh not discussed so it's hard for me
to really imagine that $5.00 super chat
from Ryan Thorp who says thanks for all
the awesome discussions and content and
a $5 super chat from Ryan Couture who
says what is your worst-case scenario
under Trump I think the authoritarianism
combined with the international ridicule
are sort of the the primary concerns and
we're seeing this every day it's the the
concerns are growing today with the
exclusion of certain so-called non
friendly non friendly media outlets
being excluded from a an off-camera
press briefing with Sean Spicer the
authoritarianism is an absolute and
total disaster if we see that continue
you could actually start to see attempts
to really crack down really crack down
on media in a way which would violate
the First Amendment at the very
beginning of this live stream nearly an
hour ago I told you that I don't think
that what happened today with Trump in
the media outlets is
a violation of the First Amendment but
you could you could definitely see that
that start to happen thank you - Angela
Harris and Benjamin Horseman who have
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership with the coupon code
I voted 17 every time I get an email as
soon as someone signs up and every time
I see it it is just heartwarming to see
people value what we are doing and now
more than 400 new members during the
month of February the shortest month of
the year and an absolute and total
record ok $6 and 66 cent super chat from
NYX
Susa who says two things I love the live
streams keep it up I would love to see
you on an hour-long podcast
Kyle kolinsky secular talk or the
humanist report yes I know both Kyle and
Mike from the humanist report and from
secular talk and the humanist report
respectively I would be glad to join
them $20 super chat from Miguel F saying
hi David love your show do you have any
favorite non news related YouTube
channels the non news related YouTube
channels that I watch I don't know if
you would like them I there is one that
is a drone review channel and I think
I've made the decision that if the david
pakman show is going to get a drone we
should go with the DJI Mavic Pro I
recently flew one and there's a picture
of me yeah there's a picture of the
drone by the way I rarely mention this I
do have an Instagram and the unique
stuff that I post online is mostly on
Instagram I'm David Pakman on Instagram
please follow me there
I tried the Mavic pro it's not getting
released formally until March 20th and I
think that that might be a good way to
go for the show especially like it folds
up so small when we travel to rallies or
protests or whatever we could bring it
and I think that would be really great
so I like that sometimes I will check
out some of the sort of like aviation
related channels I'm interested in sort
of like private pilots who do really
good filming of
their flights and that type of thing but
I can't think of really too many others
I do sometimes I'll admit this I
sometimes start my morning just while
I'm having my cappuccino to really get
fired up I combine the cappuccino with
like five minutes of Alex Jones I'll
just look at like whatever video of his
from the previous day did really well
and then then I'm basically ready ready
to go for the day
Matt zero eight zero six seventy cent
the five-dollar super chat saying how do
you respond to writer writes eiders
believing that you are a Hillary
supporter or a Lib [ __ ] because you
don't like Trump or disagree with his
policies well I mean if you can't just
say to someone not supporting Trump is
not the same as supporting Hillary if
the people don't get that I don't I
don't know I mean I would probably not
deal with those people because seems
like an exercise in futility in some
ways okay I think that's gonna do it for
today nearly an hour thanks to everybody
who joined me use that coupon code code
I voted seventeen and we will do another
live stream very very soon thank you for
joining me